what's the best airplane ever made
fighter jet ever made I know the
aviators in the in the audience are
gonna hate my answer because they're
gonna want that sexy you know muscly
F-14 Tomcat type fighter or or maybe P51
type aircraft but the F-35 is maybe not
the best dog fighter but it doesn't have
to get in a dog fight right it's like
how you'd be the best knife Fighters not
getting a knife fight sometimes Lockheed
Martin F-35 lightning II looks pretty
sexy there's two real strengths you can
have as a fighter you can you can have
the ability to kind of out muscle your
fighter uh your your opponent and beat
them on G's and power and raid around on
them and then there's the other side of
that which is uh you can be overly
maneuverable uh you can bleed energy
quickly and that's what the F-18 was
good at because it had to be heavier to
land on the aircraft carrier we had to
give an extra bulk but it also needs
special mechanism to slow down enough to
land on aircraft care and so it made it
very maneuverable and what that leads to
a lot of times the ability to get maybe
the first shot uh in a fight
um which is very good but if you do make
that sharp turn you're going to bleed a
lot of your energy away and be more
susceptible for following shots if that
one's less susceptible and so there's
just kind of aggression non-aggression
game you can play depending on the type
of aircraft you're fighting where does
that 35 land on that Spectrum the F-35
lands somewhere behind the f-22s so
there'll probably be a row of f-22s or
f-18s and F-35 will be out back but
it'll be enabling a lot of the warfare
that's happening in front of them